we continue our profiles of remarkable
women in nevada by introducing you to
marissa hawkins so a colleague nominated
hawkins after watching her incredible
stamina for raising money and caring for
others denise valdez introduces us to
the daughters of immigrants a business
owner and a tireless caregiver
in one month's time we were able to
collect 1200 services marissa hawkins
reflecting on a proud achievement
bringing together businesses to honor
healthcare heroes at the height of the
pandemic it was a time for all of us to
reflect to say how do we get back from
this get back by giving back putting
together staycation packages for
hundreds of hard-working doctors and
nurses we never want our healthcare
heroes to ever forget that they were
instrumental in keeping our community
alive and healthy that program was just
one of the reasons hawkins was nominated
as a remarkable woman that passion for
giving stems from humble beginnings i
love them so much
and
you know my dad was a mailman my mom was
a nurse as a child of immigrants she
carved out a career for herself now
owning seven massage envy locations
sacrifice and dedication are in her dna
they worked two jobs just to put my
sisters and i through school sorry
and so i know
that i wanted a better life for my
sisters in life hawkins wants to create
a better life by bringing people
together i'm very lucky because i have a
business that serves people health for
their health and wellness
and obviously able to use this business
to be able to give back to our community
she also organized a drive collecting
thousands of children's books raising
more than a hundred thousand dollars for
local vets and sharing her experience as
a public speaker her advice to others
who want to make an impact remarkable
woman is one who serves and my service
and my significance today is my service
to others denise valdez live local now